dick didn't get very specific about
whether he wants a product CEO or a tech
CEO or marketing focus CEO but he did
give some clues what was her big
takeover well you're right he's a tough
interview particularly right now when
the spotlight of the world is on I mean
he was funny a couple things jumped out
of me one the way who sings the praise
of jack dorsey you know the founder he
says nobody understands the product
better and that everyone else brings a
kind of conceptual baggage to what
Twitter is so clearly he loves Jack they
have a strong relationship the other
thing is you know I asked him to talk
about two of this executives Anthony
noto the CFO and Adam bay in the head of
sales the story he told about out of
beans hang up all night you know shows
how much state it has an atom so if you
know I wouldn't surprise me if this was
more of an internal search Anthony no
don't Adam Bain have also come up as
names potential successors heaven you
know what would you like to see in a new
CEO of Twitter I mean I'm hearing from a
lot of people that think it's just gonna
be Jack Dorsey they're not gonna do a
full search he's gonna end up with a job
and be running both where well I mean I
think they're in an incredibly strong
so dick said it earlier today that
yeah the company has the blessing being
loved by so many people and have a great
team so I think also it's been bombarded
by analysts and investors who aren't
happy yeah but I think you know that
they they have a very big business
already
I think they just need to continue to
focus on you know the basics of what are
making that business business run so I
think in their new leader they're going
to need someone who can inspire what is
already a really talented team and and
start you know sort of delivering on the
potential is coming he also insisted
grab that he has no idea what he's gonna
do next dble yet well it may be true and
then the short-term look I mean the guy
has been in under fire for five straight
years so definitely some time off and
then I babe elysium's earned another
company